BY WELCOME THEM ARE TO.
NEWEST MEMBERS.
AND THAT WOULD BE MR OR DONALD
AND AND MISS.
QUIRK SILVA AN OPERA THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK BEFORE WE
BEGIN.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO YOU JUST
WELCOME OUR ARTISTS IT'S A
PLEASURE TO BE HERE AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING ON THE
SPECIFIC ISSUES.
THANK YOU THE US ARGUES PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE
IN THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM A ONE
START A SUBCOMMITTEE.
FIVE.
OPENED THEM AGAIN SEVEN. THAT I
LIKE TO SEE US START THE
MEETING.
JUST LIKE THE STEP AND.
SANTIAGO.
HERE.
LACKEY THEIR.
BONTA.
CERVANTES.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
HOLDEN.
LOW.
MAIN SHINE.
MATHIS
THERE.
O'DONNELL.
QUIRK SILVA.
RODRIGUEZ THEIR.
BOB HOW.
YEAH.
THANK YOU AYE MR TING IF IF
YOU'D LIKE TO BEGIN ANA AB
EIGHTY SEVEN THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MOVE HIM WITH THE
MEMBERS. OF AB SEVERAL CHOIRS
COMPANIES TESTING DRIVERLESS
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES.
PROVIDE LOCAL AUTHORITIES WITH
RICK NOTICED AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES WITH THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN OUR ACTION PLAN.
VETO TO REGULATIONS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY BEING PROPOSED BY DIEM
V. THERE'S BROAD AGREEMENT THAT
THESE. REGULATIONS.
MAKE A LOT OF SENSE ESPECIALLY
WHEN YOU ARE PUTTING THESE CARS%
ON THE ROAD WITHOUT ANY PEOPLE
IN THE VEHICLES. ARE UNFORTUNATE
DMV IS MOVING AT THEIR VERY
QUICK PACE AS ALWAYS JUST TAKE
ABOUT TWO AND A HALF YEARS WITH
NO. END IN SIGHT AND ARE
CONCERNED I OR MY CONCERN IS
THAT AS THESE OUTFITS TECHNOLOGY
MOVES VERY QUICKLY WE WANT TO
CONTINUE TO MOVE QUICKLY. THAT
WE'RE GOING TO SEE MORE MORE
DEPLOYMENT IN OUR CITIES.
WE HAD THE UNFORTUNATE INCIDENT
LAST YEAR WERE.
CARS GOT DEPLOYED.
BEFORE A D. M. V. SIGNED OFF ON.
THESE VEHICLES AND OUR LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT HAD NO WAY TO
GET THESE CARS OFF THE BROUGHT.
ARE WE AS A CITY WERE
ABSOLUTELY.
INCENSED AT NOT BEING ABLE TO
GET THESE VEHICLES ON THE ROAD
SFPD CAN DO ANYTHING OUR
AMERICAN DO ANYTHING. ON IT IS
VERY VERY UNFORTUNATE BECAUSE.
WANTED APOP INNING IS WE WERE
TOLD THAT UNTIL THE A VEHICLES
ACTUALLY BROKE THE LAW WHERE
THEY HIT SOMEBODY OR DANGER TO
ME WE CAN DO ANYTHING.
SO OBVIOUSLY R. CREATED A VERY
CHALLENGING SITUATION WHICH WE
DON'T WANT TO BE IN BECAUSE WE
WANT TO BE. VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
THE TECHNOLOGY WHAT THE
TECHNOLOGY BE TESTED VERY SAFELY
I THINK THIS TECHNOLOGY IS
COMING. MUCH MUCH FASTER THAN A
LEASE I I THOUGHT.
AND I THINK IT IS ACTUALLY VERY
VERY EXCITING IN THE UP TO IS
VERY EXCITING WE ALSO WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT HAS EVERY WAITER
POLICE OF THE STREET TO MAKE
SURE THAT OUR STREETS.
ARE SAFE ARM OTHER STATES JUST
FOR EXAMPLE FOR TO ARIZONA ABOUT
A VERY PASSED LEGISLATION AYE
REGARDING THE TESTING OPERATION
OF DRIVERLESS AUTONOMOUS
VEHICLES.
AND AGAIN.
WE BELIEVE THIS IS A VERY SMALL
STEP.
BUT I THINK A VERY HELPFUL STEP
IN THIS PROCESS.
VERY GOOD YOU HAVE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES YOU'D LIKE TO CALL
FORWARD.
THE MINISTER SHARON MEMBERS ROSE
VERY SHE AND. PRESIDENT
CONSUMERS FOR AUTO RELIABILITY
SAFETY AND WE REALLY APPRECIATE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS TINGS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE WE
THINK THAT IT'S A VERY PRACTICAL
MEASURE.
VERY NARROWLY FOCUSED IT WILL
ENHANCE SAFETY.
RICK YOU.
MR TURN MEMBERS SILVIUS ALICIA
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY AND COUNTY
OF SAN FRANCISCO AS AN AYE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING INDICATED WE
ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THESE NEW
TECHNOLOGIES HOWEVER WE DO NOT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS DO NEED TO BE
INFORMED. AND PARTNERS IN THE
PROCESS OF ROLLOUT AND TESTING
OF THESE VEHICLES ON OUR STATE
THE STREETS IN ORDER TO PROTECT
PUBLIC SAFETY SO WE ASK YOUR
SUPPORT.
YOU'RE.
AFTER A CLUSTER HERNANDEZ A WE
HAVE THE CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA ROLLS IN SUPPORT.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS AYE
MISTER CHAIR.
LAURA BENNETT WITH TECH NET
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR WE ARE
MEMBERS SITUACIóN LIBRARY CEOS
WE HAVE OVER EIGHTY MEMBER
COMPANIES THE INNOVATION.
TECHNOLOGY SPACE TESTING IN THIS
AREA AYE AS YOU KNOW THE DMB IS
CURRENTLY ABOUT TO ADOPT THE
REGULATIONS THE SPECIFIC TO
DRIVER. I THOUGHT DRIVING EAGLES
WITH NO DRIVER IN THE VEHICLE.
THE LEGISLATION HAS A LANGUAGE
A.
FOR THESE REGULATIONS SPECIFIC
TO LOCAL MEDICATION IN THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT INTERACTION PLAN.
OUR CONCERNS CODIFYING THIS
LANGUAGE OF THIS TECHNOLOGY IS
BRAND NEW.
IT WILL TIE THE HANDS OF DE IN
THE THEY WILL BE ABLE TO BE
FLEXIBLE AND ADAPT TO THE
TECHNOLOGY CHANGES AS WE MOVE
FORWARD WITH THIS TECHNOLOGY.
ODD FOR THOSE REASONS WE ASK FOR
NO VOTE TODAY.
FUTURE MEMBERS LIVE IN ALL TO
MURDER HERE ON BEHALF OF GLOBAL
AUTO MAKERS AND FOR THE REASONS
JUST STATED A WE ARE ALSO IN
OPPOSED IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL A
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION A
MAMMOGRAM HALF THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS.
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
CHAIRMAN.
WELL THANK YOU VERY THEY GOT
THIS THING I THINK YOU WERE JUST
AT MY PERHAPS OF VOTING AND SO
MISTER. BUT AT THE.
APPRECIATE THE INTENT MOST
CERTAINLY FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO PROVIDE THE
FRAMEWORK OF FOR THE
TECHNOLOGIES THAT WE KNOW ARE
DIDN'T EXISTENCE.
BUT THE CONCERN I HAVE WHO.
WITH RESPECT TO THE SIMILAR TO
THE OPPOSITION WITH WITH RESPECT
TO GETTING IN FRONT OF THE DMV
WHICH IS TO SAY THAT.
UNDERSTANDING THE LEGISLATIVE
INTENT OF THOSE OF US AS THE
LEGISLATIVE BODY GETTING IN
FRONT OF THE REGULATORY AND AT
THAT AT THAT YOU CAN HELP
ELABORATE ON THE INSIDE AND
UTSIDE THE COULD LOOK AT THE
GREAT EXAMPLE I THINK I TEND TO.
ALSO FEEL THAT WAY IN MANY
CASES I THINK IN THIS CASE WE
INTRODUCED THIS BILL. A LAST
TRIP THIS TIME AND WE ACTUALLY
HELD IT THE THE PROVISIONS
WITHIN THE BILL WERE ACTUALLY
MUCH STRONGER IN TERMS OF. A
WHAT WE ALLOWED LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO DO US WOULD
PURPOSELY WAITED HELD BACK.
WANTED TO SEE WHAT DIEM BE WAS
GOING TO DO IT WAS OUR HOPE THAT
DIEM VIEW COULD HAVE RATIFIED
THESE REGULATIONS LAST YEAR. SO
A YEAR LATER.
WE HAVE ON THEM REGULATIONS
THAT ARE THERE IN IN AGREEMENT
BUT IF FOR WHATEVER REASON THEY
HAVEN'T BEEN COMPLETELY.
RATIFIED BY THE DEPARTMENTS I
THINK A WEEK VERY RESPECTFUL OF
WHAT DIEM V. NEEDS TO DO.
THEY NEED TO DO THEIR JOB BUT I
THINK AS A LAWMAKERS WITH TO DO
OUR JOB AS WELL TO MAKE SURE
THAT WERE PROTECTING OUR
CITIZENS OUR STREETS. A DMV AS
YOU KNOW THEY AND THEY DON'T
REALLY HEAR OUR CONSTITUENTS
WHEN THEY COMPLAIN THEY CALL OUR
OFFICES.
WHEN WHEN LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
NEEDS HELP CLEAN WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO SEE IF.
WE CAN FIND AGREEMENT I AND I
UNDERSTAND.
THEIR THEIR OBJECTION I THINK
IT'S VERY REASONABLE THAT
WORKING THROUGH THIS PROCESS BUT
WE ALSO FEEL THAT AT THIS POINT
HOME WE DON'T WANT TO WAIT
FOREVER FOR THESE REGULATIONS TO
NOT. HERE TO BE CODIFIED R. MADE
MAYBE THEY'LL NEVER BECOME.
TICKET.
AB.
I THINK MR TING FOR FOR BEGIN
THIS THIS BILL FORWARD UP ARE
YOU SEE THAT YOU KNOW I THINK WE
ALL AGREE THAT THAT WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE WE ACT ACTING HAVE THE
SAFETY OF OUR CONSTITUENTS IN I
RESIDENT. I DID JUST WANNA.
ECHO SOME THE CONCERNS MADE BY
MISTER LOW JUST ABOUT THE SORT
OF POTENTIAL DUPLICATIVE. ARM
NATURE.
MAYBE ALSO. I'M HAVING A LITTLE
LESS WITH THEM.
AWHILE AGO SO WASN'T JUST
OBVIOUSLY THE BILL WAS JUST
CHANGED IMPRINT ON LAST WEEK BUT
THE INFORMATION THAT WE PUT IN
PRINT WAS SHARED WITH THEM.
AWHILE AGO OF THAT THAT'S WHY WE
CHOSE WHO WE BELIEVE THAT THE
TWO PROVISIONS AROUND LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND ALSO THE ONES
THAT REALLY WE DON'T ANTICIPATE
CHANGING.
WE WE THINK WHAT'S THESE
VEHICLES NEED TO BE DEPLOYED
THERE SHOULD BE A LAW
ENFORCEMENT PLAN PERHAPS TO BE A
LAW ENFORCEMENT PLANT AND EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF OUR KITTIES
CATHOLIC THE MINIMUM. THE OTHER
MINIMUM SHOULD BE THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT SHOULD BE INFORMED
WHERE THIS TESTING IS GOING TO
TAKE PLACE.
SO THAT THEY CAN IF THEY NEED TO
PROVIDE EXTRA SECURITY ARE THEY
NEED TO.
BE AWARE OF THE SITUATION THAT
THEY CAN THEY CAN MONITOR BILLY
USE THAT AS OUR GUIDES.
THAT'S REALLY ALL THE PROVISIONS
THAT WERE CODIFIED SO AGAIN TO
MEET THE OTHER PROVISIONS THAT.
FORM THE VERY BASELINE OF SAFETY
THE ABSOLUTE MINIMUM STANDARDS
SAFETY OBVIOUSLY THE REGULATIONS
THAT ARE BEING CODIFIED DISCUSS
ARE GONNA BE DOING A WHOLE LOT
MORE THAN THAT. BUT THIS TO ME
OUR HELPS ENSURE THAT WE HAVE A
BASELINE OF SAFETY WITH THE
BASELINE OF A HAVING THESE
COMPANIES WORK DIRECTLY WITH
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT WHICH I
THINK IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
RIGHT NOW THE PRIMARY
INTERACTIONS WITH DMV.
SO THERE'S NOT ANY OBLIGATION
NECESSARILY BUT LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT SO THIS DISQUALIFIES
THAT ARE AS THIS TECHNOLOGY IS
DEPLOYED NOT ONLY SHOULD YOU BE
WORKING FOR THE REGULATORY
FRAMEWORK WITH DMB BUT THAT YOU
REALLY NEED TO BE. TALKING
HANDED AND HAVING A PLAN WITH
LOCAL LAW FIRST BECAUSE IN THE
END THEY'RE THE ONES CHARGED
WITH.
PROVIDING SAFETY OUR STREETS.
I THINK MR TO.
YES I AM.
SOME MIGHT THINK IT RINGS BEFORE
OF A SHE WITH MY BACKGROUND OF
PUBLIC SAFETY IN AND.
MAKE SURE THAT WE PROVIDE THE.
FOLKS OUT THERE THAT ARE TAKING
CARE OF US WITH THIS THE POLICE
OR FIRE DEPARTMENTS BECAUSE OF
SEE THERE'S A LOT LIKE TRUNKS IN
THESE VEHICLES.
HOW DO THEY RESPOND TO THESE
ACCIDENTS ON THE FREEWAY OR
SPIDER INTO A BUILDING? THERE'S
LOT TECHNOLOGY OUT THERE THAT I
THINK FOR THE RIGHT REASONS WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE WE.
HAVE THAT DISCUSSION WITH WITH
THE POLICE FIRE PLEASE
DEPARTMENT PART FROM THE LOCAL
AGENCIES PROVIDING SERVICE.
BECAUSE IT IS A TECHNOLOGIST
INVOLVING CHANGING DAY BY DAY
BUT JUST ONE VICTORY CONTINUE
HAVING THAT DISCUSSION WITH
OPPOSITION HOPING I THINK.
TO THEIR ISSUES AS WELL BUT IT'S
SOMETHING THAT DEFINITELY NEED
TO MAKE SURE COMMITTEES ARE
SAFE.
MORE THESE OF BECAUSE BE
OPERATING THANK YOU ABSOLUTE
THANK YOU AND AND YEAH WE GOT MY
COMMITTEE WILL CONTINUE TO KEEP
WORKING WITH OPPOSITION
ABSOLUTE.
BUT SEE ANYMORE COMMENTS I WAS
GONNA MOVE THE BILL.
CLICK.
JUST A REALLY APPRECIATE ALL THE
ALL THE COMMENTS AGAIN WE WANT
TO CONTINUE WORK WITH.
THE OPPOSITION THIS IS THIS IS
TECHNOLOGY THAT IS
EXTRAORDINARILY IMPORTANT THAT
WE WANT TO CONTINUE TO. ALLOW TO
DEVELOP.
BUT WE WANT TO DO IT IN A SAFE
PLACE TO REALLY APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE'S CONSIDERATION.
WE WOULD NEED A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
FIRST
A SECOND ON THIS RODRIGUEZ.
MADAM SECRETARY UP THE CHAIR OF
A CONDITION IS A YES.
MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
ROLE.
BUSH'S DO PASTA APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO AYE LACKEY
NO.
LACKEY NO BONTA.
I BONTA AYE CERVANTES.
CERVANTES AYE.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE LOW.
LOW AYE MAGI.
MATHIS.
MATHIS NO O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE.
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA I'VE RODRIGUEZ ARE
RODRIGUEZ AYE VOTE PAL.
NO.
FOR PONO.
EIGHT TO THREE MEASURES OUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CRESCENTA
AND YOU.
IT WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN. UP
FOR THREE MINUTES FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
THANK YOU.
BUT UNNAO
WHAT WHILE WE'RE WAITING FOR
BURKE.
ALLEN TAKE A POINT OF PERSONAL
PRIVILEGE AND I WANT US AND AND
I'M ON TV SO I WANT TO SAY HAPPY
BIRTHDAY TO BOTH CHEST PRETE.
I TOLD IN OUR OFFICE SO IF YOU
SEE HER WILSHIRE HOBBY BIRTHDAY
FOR THE NEXT WEEK.
AND ALSO ONCE A HAPPY BIRTHDAY
TO.
JACKIE CAME A GUARD TO TO STAFF
SO IF YOU SEE HER SAY HAPPY
BIRTHDAY.
.
IF MR.
IF MR GARCIA HAD NOT SHOWED UP
ABBOUD REVEALED AGES.
SO.
AB EIGHTY SEVEN EDUARDO GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA AYE.
MAIN GIANT.
ONLY THE ROLE BUT FOR ANOTHER
TWO MINUTES UP FOR MISTER MAY
TRYING TO COME.
AND IN THE MEANTIME EMBARRASS
BOTH A JACQUI AND JUST SPREE
ONCE MORE HAPPY BIRTHDAY
OKAY.
BOB ECONOMIC.
YEAH.
ANY PARTY LARA'S.
YEAH START AFTER.
MY COMMITTEE.
YEAH LOTS OF
BUT WE SHOULDN'T BE.
BECAUSE Q..
YEAH.
HIS EYES WERE
MEN SECRETARY. AB EIGHTY SEVEN
MAIN GIANT.
WHEN CHINA.
MEMBERS THIS.
FINAL VOTE IS NINE TO FOUR
MEMBERS THIS CONCLUDES OUR
BUSINESS FOR THE DAY THE HEARING
IS NOW ADJOURNED